what did you learn about your method of
pitching you'd said you were a little
nervous at one point you felt you rushed
it or said something well you know I
started out basically at heart I'm a
stand-up comedian that's how i started i
used to open for Woody Allen I mean I
was very successful at it and as a
stand-up comedian all stands come used
you read the audience becomes an
instinct maybe you're born with it i
mean i think i was because i just am a
natural storyteller but a funny story
teller and you listen you you find out
because i never wrote anything when i
was a stand-up comedian I never wrote
and know how to write I mean you give me
a white piece of paper and I would
freeze what i would do is i would get up
on the stage and i would talk about my
my day or something that happened to me
you know that i thought was funny that I
told my friend and I'll tell you the
coffee houses back in the day and you
listen to what the audience laughs at
what they're interested in you can feel
it or hear it and after a while it
becomes a learned instinct that you
would have a photographic memory for
laughs I have a photographic memory for
laughs if I entertained you or told you
stories about myself I would just be
talking and we were to be having a
conversation kind of one-sided but a
conversation and if I had to go up on
the stage I could go up on the stage and
tell the same story I told you but made
it much shorter I could tell the story
just for the laughs I would kind of my
mind would kind of well that's an
instinct I have I don't you know I don't
write it down and remember or try to
remember where you left I don't I just
tell the story and all the stuff you
didn't laugh at drops out and that's how
I worked as a stand-up comedian so
that's how I kind of it's kind of an
instinct you know you're just born with
it like you know comic timing you you
really can't teach that that something
you're born with you know some people
are born musicians with some have a
perfect year pitch you know you just go
with what you know
what are you good at I guess what you
like
you